c'est une victoire qui pourrait laisser
des traces après plus de six heures de
réunion virtuelle le comité exécutif du
parti chrétien démocrate a désigné armes
ils l'achètent comme le candidat
conservateur à la chancellerie lors des
élections législatives déjà élu
président de la cds ou en janvier il
tentera donc de succéder à angela merkel
à la tête du gouvernement fédéral
allemand
ce mardi son adversaire marcus hodder
champion de la cs ou l'alter ego
bavarois de la cdu ou a reconnu sa
défaite
mettant fin à plusieurs jours de lutte
interne armin laschet tu appelle
maintenant à l'unité au sein du
mouvement
ce qui compte désormais c'est de savoir
quel parti a les meilleurs concepts pour
l'avenir de notre pays et qu'ils forment
la meilleure équipe pour relever nos
différents défis c'est pourquoi il est
maintenant important pour l'union cd ou
cs ou d'entrer dans la campagne
électorale comme une équipe
la cds ou ne gagnera pas cette élection
sans la cs ou et inversement
les ténors du parti ont préféré soutenir
le centriste l'achète qui entend
s'inscrire en héritier direct de la
ligne modérée et européennes dans gala
merkel pourtant face à lui marcus odeurs
semblait être le candidat de droite avec
la meilleure cote de popularité dans les
sondages en vue des législatives de
septembre
un choix qui pourrait menacer l'alliance
cd août ses sous déjà fragilisée par la
politique d'accueil des migrants mise en
oeuvre par angela merkel depuis 2015 une
division que l'opposition ne se prive
pas de souligner l'achète et ceux d'air
ne s'intéresse qu'au pouvoir ils sont
passés à côté des vrais enjeux
surtout à un moment où le pays est aux
prises avec la pandémie leur différend
était irresponsable et non professionnel
la lutte pour le pouvoir laisse une
union déchiré et de profondes blessures
face à des conservateurs diviser les
verts qu'il est à l'ombre dans les
intentions de vote s'impose comme l'art
adversaire principal
les écologistes ont eux affiché leur
unité à travers un processus de
désignation harmonieux
c'est leur co présidente anna lena
bareback qui a été choisi pour se lancer
à la conquête de la chancellerie